le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais la capitale
française est connu dans le monde entier
pour son charme ses monuments et son
allure romantique
on y vient du monde entier en tant que
touriste
mais on y vient aussi pour faire ses
études il n'est pas toujours facile de
se loger quand on est étudiant
les loyers sont chers et les places rare
même et surtout en cité universitaire
parmi les cités universitaires
l'une d'entre elles réservées aux
étudiants ayant déjà obtenu une licence
fait l'objet de toutes les convoitises
la cité internationale universitaire de
paris les places y sont rares et très
sélective
on y vient du monde entier pour s'y
loger
pourtant certains étudiants réunionnais
ils y ont aussi accès
comment cela a été possible on en parle
maintenant d'un lien social
jonathan est un jeune étudiant
réunionnais derrière son allure modeste
et tranquille se cache un étudiant
d'excellence
jonathan n'a pas un master mais deux
master en biologie un en français et un
en anglais
après avoir obtenu son baccalauréat à la
réunion je n'atteins dû partir en
métropole dans un domaine qui le
passionne mais qui n'est pas enseigné à
la réunion après avoir fini un
baccalauréat la réunion je suis parti
sur strasbourg tout d'abord où j'ai
étudié à l'université louis pasteur j'ai
fait ma première licence mon master 1 et
j'ai finalement réussi après avoir fait
des demandes à intégrer l'université
whip pierre et marie curie à paris 6 et
une très bonne très bonne université en
biologie à la réunion en biologie en
fait ça reste ça reste assez limitée sur
certains domaines notamment ils sont
très bons en dessous ce qui est biologie
marine environnement ils ont des bons
débuts laboratoire en cancérologie
mais j'ai vraiment
envie d'aller dans la biologie du
vieillissement de la longévité c'est un
sujet qu'ils ont pas encore du tout
abordé à la réunion comme dans beaucoup
de pays français pourtant c'est un sujet
majeur donc c'est vraiment moi ça m'a
toujours intéressé je savais que ça
allait être porteur et c'est vraiment le
masters de mes rêves en eau après avoir
obtenu sa licence avec d'excellents
résultats
jonathan postulent à l'université paris
6 grâce à ses très bons résultats
il est tout naturellement accepté dans
la spécialité qui le passionne mais se
loger à paris est extrêmement compliqué
surtout quand on est encore étudiant et
sans revenu fixe mais heureusement le
conseil général de la réunion soutient
les jeunes réunionnais qui veulent
étudier sur paris ou dans d'autres
régions de france le département de la
réunion a ainsi établi un partenariat
avec la prestigieuse série super cité
internationale universitaire de paris
afin de soutenir l'aspiration croissante
des jeunes réunionnais à la mobilité et
de leur réserver des chambres dans un
espace où se côtoient 120 nationalités
différentes se loger sur paris c'est
très difficile et donc
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai fait appel
pour pouvoir rentrer dans cette enclave
qu'ils ont en fait ce cette enclave
qu'ils ont dans paris qui permet
d'accueillir les étudiants réunionnais
ou des autres pays des dom qui
souhaitent faire des études supérieures
donc après une licence sur paris c'est
pas comment je m'en lasse et
internationale et aussi beaucoup de
choses qui entrent en compte beaucoup
d'intérêt être la cité internationale
on rencontre énormément de personnes qui
sont toutes très intéressantes qui sont
toutes des gens qui sont battus pour
arriver là où ils en sont et qui ont
vraiment envie de faire ce qu'ils font
et d'une sorte de passion qui cherche à
communiquer et c'est des gens partout
dans le monde notamment grâce au
programme d'échangé entre les maisons
qui permet à des gens qui viennent dans
notre pays de se retrouver dans une
autre maison s'ils ont envie de se
baigner plusieurs zones de culture
vraiment rencontre des gens de toutes
les origines
on échange beaucoup et ça tu peux quand
on rentre chez soi on a aussi un
brassage intellectuelle et aussi
beaucoup de bonne ambiance le coût des
simples comme un programme erasmus
mundus à de supers profits records
depuis plusieurs années nous aidons les
étudiants réunionnais et ce sont cette
année 20 millions d'euros que nous avons
mis à disposition à contribution pour
aider
dix mille étudiants réunionnais mais là
c'est assez formidable parce que la cité
internationale universitaire qui est
très prisé demandé par toutes les
nationalités nous avons nous à quota
réservé mais on donne on offre là des
conditions idéales pour que les jeunes
puissent avoir un bon loyer avec les
conditions aussi que vous avez vues dans
le reportage les meilleurs fonds réussie
à 93 % des étudiants qui sont passés à
la sérénité a obtenu leur diplôme grâce
au soutien du conseil général des
étudiants réunionnais ambitieux peuvent
se concentrer sur leurs études et
décroché diplômes les plus prestigieux
dans les domaines qu'ils souhaitent et
revenir à la réunion pour mettre leurs
connaissances au service des réunionnais
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais